yeah hello welcome to this video this is
coverage of the final round and the
playoff of the London chess classic yep
it's over that event and all ready for
two days to relate this video but
couldn't do it any earlier yeah the
final round and the tiebreak we had a
tie-break after that round which kind of
sports a little bit if you it's unlikely
but if you don't know the result of the
event on the final round had five games
of course but I mean I want to really
make it short and with them with those
games and look just at a couple of
decisive moments because the final round
had one particularly interesting game
and decisive game and the rest of the
games we were really rather boring and
then we had this this tie break which
was played for for all of it so um let's
be quick with the games I don't want to
skip games altogether but let's just be
brief and geary own was probably the
least interesting game of the round and
we get a bill in defense again and while
Arnold has a rotten event is on a minus
score and geary is on plus two it
definitely does not want to lose this
and hell out of her out of competition
for the overall win but well yeah he's
not going to play something crazy and
its own what did that print out my
friend ever own print out here yeah I
had a printout commentary for that game
when I had a note about the novelty that
was plated you know I'm going through
this quickly you know why because that
has been played already more than once
all this is no one we see their gear es
spend seven minutes here in the round
here there is a novelty and I mean we
already have a completely draw position
check
and here they drew or what give you did
was play like 26 757 moves of book and
then one or two old moose term yeah and
I'd spend a little bit more time there
maybe he was still looking here if we
can find something interesting over the
board but well it's a bit too late
probably yeah that line is leading
nowhere for for any side um and yeah I
kind of understand the rationale behind
this game but it's still not
particularly interesting to watch and in
a similar note we had Nakamura to Paolo
let's load that one both probably not
playing for much to Paolo is already on
minus four you got no wind in and know
with black it's difficult to believe
that he would get something yeah and
Nakamura has lost two games and now is
on minus one so not to check that great
prospects there anyway they have a
Berlin and they played it in a little
bit of a unconventional way but it's
difficult to get something truly
interesting here around here when I was
when I saw the gamer thought that white
might be able to try for a little
something but it seems that Apollo
defended this quite okay and yeah yeah
she looks pretty nice for white but it's
nothing substantial f4 is hanging and
you don't have a clear way forward this
was played by like I'm world she ate
here they repeat it I think it was just
yeah but for both they were glad that
this this thing is over I mean
photopolymer it was a whole nightmare
that event and nakamura had a really
good event up to that plus one squad
then he lost to Carlton and afterwards
to geary so
pretty a pretty bad end for the American
number one okay we had Adams Caruana and
both of those players had mmm eight
drawers up to that round so there I mean
every everything that you know about
statistics points towards this game
being a draw and well it it ended in a
draw they had this this line that neo
argh engelska with Bishop to c5 and b5
get Adams played in a very safe way with
d3 and and so on well just one
interesting moment there with g4 and
Bishop g5 that was an active way here by
Adams sometimes white gets in stuff like
night here night here Queen gf3 this
kind of ideas but corona is immediately
striking in the center and clarifies the
whole situation and yeah around here I
thought that maybe White has something
with this bishops but it is at the end
isn't anything because Queenie five is a
good move at the text here and here and
it essentially forces this thing yeah
and here we get to the point where basic
an almost all of us would manage to draw
probably against corona or Adams no
matter what yeah it's just a dead wrong
white can't hear never move ahead as you
will lose the c3 point when you can but
then then it's an entirely it's a
completely dead position so um let's say
I don't know black stays white takes
black takes until you just stay and have
a draw basically by just shuffling yeah
kind of a nothing game as i said the
games in the final round were even less
thrilling than in the rounds before
there was just one spectacular game that
we're going to see shortly we had
Aronian against mvl aronia on +1 mvl on
plus two so with the wind live one
actually
join the co-lead um it's um this line
yeah pretty solid choice by MD out and
not easy to do anything with white
Aronian went for III it's an interesting
alternative g3 is of course the main
move and also think the move that white
should play if he is striving for
anything even though um of course all
this year's super solid for black um
it's probably still the way to go for
white just feels more logical to feel
cheto then play in their Center here
yeah don't get me wrong I'm not saying
that aronian displaying unload gical
Chester just that yeah I think that if
you if you look here right this is what
happened this kind of thing I don't
think that white has got anything here
it usually leads to some simplification
in the center like it happen TN this
kind of thing and here why just plays
for nothing like it's totally fine if
you ask me I'd rather be black here but
it's it's it's equal of course so they
they played this position of course but
it's very little to play for all white
spawn structures is damaged here with
this week aged porn black has double
points but those are actually kind of
useful they control imported squares and
why does somewhat stuck to that age bond
and it makes it difficult for y to move
his majority is falling against three
the double porn the isolated pawn so mvl
went for some counter play on the
queenside the tea after Bishop f5 it was
time for aronia Jim yeah simplify this
down to a draw this is a good move here
rook h1 just tossing that pawn and now
getting activity for the book yeah it's
just a draw when can you do it check
yeah they played it on a little bit but
here they agree to a draw it's just
nothing to play for it all so these were
the uneventful game
and I purposely went to them very
quickly it doesn't really make much
sense to and try to find any big
subtleties where they weren't or let's
say they are not interesting enough that
you would want to spend lots of time on
it let's now have a look at the games
that decided the whole thing got cars
and we shook this was a very very
important game for both players actually
cause um needed a win to get them to the
to the leader of the event and ya get to
that mentioned tiebreak and grease oak
also needed a wind to get to the
tiebreak and with this he also would
have chances to get enough points to get
the overall third place in the grand
chest or which would be the qualifier
for next year's serious very interesting
appoint them so it's not just I mean of
course Grichuk likes to win that game
and maybe em get into the tie backs of
the event but qualifying for next year's
tour is a really really important thing
because it's guaranteed income and those
are professionals that they need they
need the money as we all do to pay off
our dinners or breakfasts and I don't
know few children in Google's case um
yeah so he wants to wants to get to the
third place of the water needs a win
they both need a win so what do we have
bi trans position regardless a Solian
chaso check that's kind of interesting
you remember that game there was a game
Carson to Palo in San Luis first round
when to pull off now unleashed the crazy
move g5 head Grisha plays it again of
course this is the kind of kind of thing
that shows that he is a true gambling I
man is a piece of poker players
well-greased August so yeah this is the
kind of move that you make if you want
to win and you don't mind taking a risk
it's a it's not objectively bad it seems
but it's really a cool
to just play it against Carson who has
lost against this room friends that's
two part of and he certainly has to have
something in store here okay Calvin took
it 95 back and black takes this pawn so
this is the idea of the whole thing you
trade the g pawn against the sea pawn
and in general you get get a completely
murky position I mean I'm a pretty
classical player and I don't really
believe in this kind of stuff for black
but it doesn't seem to be a particularly
bad or anything the computer is not able
to refute it just like that of course
not even if it would be possible Bishop
wouldn't have played it um yeah 93 this
is the new move them in the mentioned
Carlton to pile of game console plate 9
a-3 and this was something that he had
to find back then over the board yeah it
was surprised by g5 and well here Knight
c3 is the result of preparation yeah
look be aight i would see grew shop
taking time yeah it's not that he
prepared something super deep eh seems
rugby 8 and rook f1 yeah interesting
choice because he also takes time it's
not a completely this is not one some
kind of yeah some kind of computer
created preparation that is just
repeated they really seem to play at him
look i have one aged 6 and 9 drops back
and night 23 yeah this is this is really
modern chester the night is moving again
this is something that you can never
show any of your chest units as a
straight as a chess teacher because I
mean they both are I mean especially
black as violating all kinds of rule see
I am pushing the Jeep on early the beep
oh yeah I mean v5g five on two
consecutive moves and then blackest
moving is not around all the time and
they're putting it on d3 okay there is
some of course some
some sense with this move because if you
take on air three you just develop wide
and hear you you stop the depot from
moving okay nighty one played by cards
and yeah he wants to get rid of that
night as soon as possible and yeah we
should decided to grab that porn on
between so this happened and Bishop
takes it for yeah I think that in this
position should favor white why is that
my evaluation I think that long-term
white should be a little bit better here
because his King is safer now he's got a
very safe King those three pawns are
ideally placed and it not so clear what
blacks king is doing in the long run
yeah 11 we will that I sometimes
sometimes tell people they ask me what
about King safety is if you play b5 and
g5 and both though both those moves you
will never have a safe King and this is
pretty a pretty true i think for example
if you think there are lines in the end
time Aaron semi Slava black place both
well then he never gets a safe King so
what happens here rugby form Queen up
dead c 2 p-6 will be one that rook is
traded and now the night comes over to
e3 we see that like it's lacking that
Jeep on it's got some pieces to cover
the king though it's not like white he
has a decisive attack or so I'm just
saying that long term it is easier for
why to play because you have an idea
what to do where you can attack the king
you have a pretty decent central control
those three pieces and the pawn I get
towards d5 like a not easily get in d5
here om bit pretty much you can never
get that in so I think why does a little
bit more comfortable and f5 for supply
of course what white wants to do is if
possible increase the pressure only six
and make that pawn move if it moves
let's say it moves up easy five would be
terrible that gives away the d5 square
for white and makes this look very
stupid or if he takes
also then what again gets more control
over d5 it has this attacking chance so
black wants to keep this keep this
tension he went a5 a4 Queen back Queen
wants to help on the other side of the
board yeah and now Bishop to a 6 that is
also somewhat logical move Bishop c4
looked more active than bishop on CA but
if you trade those you have chances to
get more on the light squares black took
it and play tonight h5 looking at those
weakened squares and also looking to
maybe do something with the bishop to e5
or to c4 yeah so we've got a very tense
situation um we also see that Carlton
has much more time on the clock Ashok as
usual was drifting into time trouble
ruke f3 that's rather logical route g8
yeah and now Carlton goes form something
very young ambitious and I'm not really
sure that I like the move I think it's
objectively not so great he went nite b5
yeah just going for this poll and it
it's a move that now needs to a yeah
pretty wild complication that ultimately
will lead to yeah I decisive result in
this game we should be five and 94 that
was his idea but Greece shock was
playing this well he played Queen to h4
and now we see that there are all blacks
pieces are involved in the attack on
White's king and the queen is offside
this is often an alarming sign if the
queen is offside and cannot help in
defense very often there's a majority of
attackers against defenders yeah here
cousin um move 13 makes a pretty
substantial mistake that should have
cost him the game and overall chances to
him to win the whole thing he took on
his six and that should lose actually
what
what is it what he should have taken
only five the thing is it's possible
it's really possible that he saw that
this move which looks completely normal
that this move is just a draw and that
he yeah that he simply simply only
looked at okay this is a drawer I have
to do something else and didn't really
look so much or in that much depth if
the alternative is any good yeah well
this is a joy I'm sorry this is this is
one drawing line check check
alternatively if you go up here after d5
you can lose as night f4 or night g3
will be decisive depending on what what
white is doing this would have been a
drawer night XD five also after nine txt
5d takes d5 it's a draw but white has to
find night 26 and this is still kind of
complicated but we're also at the end
lead to a draw so night xt5 that was the
logical outcome of the game but Carson
took on e6 probably just I know did she
take long not so much maybe he just just
saw that the other stuff is some is a
draw and let's go for this um the thing
is that now route takes you four seems
to win and this was not played back we
shocked if we should get the line here
this is the key idea black now a text
with Bishop 9 and queen and white has no
defense it's um it's really pretty
awkward gym if Luke g3 for example to
cover here black just takes on e6 and
what is why it's supposed to do now you
know that is hanging if you go here you
just go back this kind of thing black
just has a big attack yeah 9h for maybe
I didn't look at this so much and then
look f7 seems to still be okay
but you can also just consolidate you a
little bit and then go from there but if
white goes for a counter-attack here on
that night f4 is going to be decisive
something like that it's just very awful
yeah that was the big opportunity for
Grisha group takes before he didn't do
that not sure what he missed mmm he took
only six no cards into 225 and this now
again is a draw yeah if black plays it
right quinta Queenie one yeah maybe he
also avoided that because he wanted to
win yeah I'm not sure this is a very
weird kind of situation because both
players know that they cannot make a
draw and I mean you can also say that
maybe a vm yeah council didn't mind to
give though opponent that opportunity
because you felt that you wanted to win
it's very tough to say what was kind of
like if you want some kind of match
strategy some some metal strategy
because of the world standing or if they
just played the moves that they failed
they were right and just missed things
it's definitely possible I mean a wish
six-party was down to five minutes he
can calculate amazing stuff in this kind
of in kind of time but don't
underestimate the nerve some and things
like that yeah okay here Queenie one
check was the draw again there is this
check drawing variation that we already
have seen it's important to note that
this move here is not working at all as
night f four wins outright very strong
move threatening mate and this is an
also made pretty nice but Grisha took
this is no mistake it just it keeps the
draw in hand but it is now difficult to
draw after Queen 2x6 here black has to
find the way to draw and this is 32 g 5
this is there also the only move that
draws it is a car it's looking rather
logical we carry
cover this and this both bones were
hanging was check but seeing that it is
drawing is actually difficult yeah here
rucca have two nite f4 it's giving black
enough play Quincy form jigs ticks and
ticks he is ok for black at the end yeah
I mean black spawns are not especially
pretty but white structures also not
ideal at all so black will probably draw
this without big problems there are some
funny lines here if white is decided to
go g4g form night f4 we know five
Queenie seven let's rather interesting
now black has the idea to play route
gave eight trapping the Queen and it's
funny that the only move that seems to
draw here for white this is the move
Knight 287 which is really looking crazy
the ideas 96 said after we have eight
you have 96 and then a 504 very funny
line here why does even better yeah but
it's a draw though with root g5 them
sorry g5 check what am I doing here look
at g5 queenside rook g8 and it's a
perpetual here in a way on the on the
Queen yeah some funny lines after Queen
g5 that would have drawn but Greece joke
didn't didn't play that Jack he played
the check and after that white is
winning yeah both Luke everyone and King
edge to wins King edge to was played by
my cousin and now black is out of it out
of fire out of firepower I am it can
take the two here which didn't it took
on g2 but this is also not going to work
as this is saying it was check and
something like this check check for
example is a pretty clean win for white
his own one porn up but also has so much
bye
to position yeah something like Queen
Queen here check check and here that's
going to be a very easy job for cars the
Agri shop tried that sacrifice on g 2
i'm actually surprised and it's the
first time that I see the actual clock
chimes I was suspecting when I saw the
moves I didn't see the game life i was
playing myself that the day I'm I
suspected that we shook had no time on
the clock but he actually had like two
minutes yeah TM Jack Queen d2 it is
winning now for White Queen ito was a
little bit tougher but ultimately also
also win for example rook f2 noise I
have four check king g3 is winning for
white it looks oh yeah but it is winning
something like this and this is indeed
winning that hangs but this Queen also
hangs an end game like that is a win for
wide yeah those pawns are just far too
weak and go for while white spawns are
much more solid here so this was played
in the game and now check this isn't
difficult anymore check this is no check
because the queen is protecting check
check and here we shook resigned so cars
at the end got to a plus to score yeah
and got to play that mentioned tiebreak
yeah so what did they do now yeah they
played a tie-break for the wind of that
event and for the wind of the tour with
it because the horse standings was so
were close that the winner of that of
the tiebreak would also win the award to
her in case of mdl winning the tiebreak
they would have had to
had to make a playoff with cars it was
pretty complicated let's say let's just
look at the games and we'll figure out
what happened first of all they had
three players tying mvl geary and carson
and what they did is and i never liked
this kind of concept but it's something
that also has done in tournaments like
gibraltar for example they basically
sort the three players by a tie-break
system in this case case the zona borne
by agha system which means they add up
who you have won against and basically
the guy who beat the players with more
points has the better better tie break
and this is kalyn dead in that regard
because he beat gris shock and and
nakamura and giving and and mdl that
they beat Apollo and and honored and
giving Casey been a camera but on points
cards and was was leading this so
Carlton was seeded let's say for the
final of the tiebreak and gearing and
MDL had to play a player who is playing
cards so this is now rapid chess and I
don't want to be too critical of the
moves because afterwards we check it
with computers and can see quite quickly
some things that are very tough to spot
in a rapid game I just want to look at a
couple of key moments they played two
25-minute games with five second
increment okay no surprise I get our own
sound favorite opening here the Berlin
defense and give replays and
interestingly with b6 we should be seven
yeah that's it setup seems to be quite
interesting for black I mean interesting
it's not like yeah you're going to open
the champagne bottles and celebrate but
it seems to be very very sound and what
mvl is coming up here is is exactly
nothing it's it's kind of interesting
how quickly why it is in trouble here
that idea Bishop g5 and taking I
actually already don't like so much
and I mean black now gets a very safe
position with his King only seven and
gets his rooks connected yeah it's
definitely okay for black disposition
even though why does not need to be
worse as it happened in the game if wide
now goes tonight f1 at same I think he's
okay there was an older game from 2012
not old by chip arena grand master chip
arena with white playing David navara
and it ended in a draw ultimately 9f for
ya and this move was just not good I'm
not quite sure what mb i was going for
him after c5 now the bishop is opened up
and 95 yeah and since worth pointing out
that this is just really bad can you
sexist it's a double attack and you
cannot take here as now the night will
get trapped it's really awful so we had
to go here and now give reissues
protecting that pond kicks the night
back and activates the king black is
essentially playing with a an active
King now and from here I think if mvl
plays perfectly is still kind of okay
but he makes the odd the author
inaccurate move king f2 is kind of hmm
now he probably should prevent this H
form of even though it's not a big deal
but it gets a big deal now as he plays
King to you three and this is probably
leading to to his defeat 95 was still
kind of okay now covering the porn like
that if black takes it and grabs here
then route d7 is enough counter play
yeah and the problem of this move is
Luke e8 very strong move intending f6
and why that's not really getting out of
this it's really amazing how bad this
position now becomes um yeah what is so
mvl supposed to do he cannot go back
here the king will take
so 95 and then this f6 was coming I know
why does in big trouble ruge f1 check
check and the King just stepped to the
side it's important here to note that
white cannot play King e4s that leads a
total mess yeah I mean no disaster check
checkmate it's made very funny made King
you for what's not possible so we had to
give up their port it was not possible
to cover it anymore check and here check
check Black has a technically winning
endgame yeah I don't think we need to
look at this so much now it was a pretty
clean affair check what black has to do
is keep control he has the bishop
dominating the night and he has got that
porn check also better King check that's
four players of that caliber it's no
problem at all to win this kind of
position we three were four see fallen
for pretty awful so very good start
forgiving in that in that playoff
tiebreak then next game they've led two
games so mvl now had to win with black
it was the only chance to do something
yeah I want to go straight to the
endgame basically they played a somewhat
yes Louis line of the fianchetto
Greenfeld yeah and I think what was
curious problem here a little bit it
felt like he was even he was okay with
the draw yeah because the draw would
have given him the spot to play cards
but he played a little bit passively
with white share on some occasions and
at the end he got to a position we jump
to move 44 soonish we're black was a
little bit more active yeah the rook is
a bit active here and all in all it's a
easier for black to play this position
but here he could have yeah gotten
decent enough a position with g4 he
should just go g4 and keep this this
whole thing yeah intact going for this
and this possibly he went 98 however
directly attacking those pawns and now
after Luke edge to it is a little bit
trickier now because that pawn gets lost
and black has some initiative with the
pawns their check yeah this is a an
interesting moment here night e seven
was played black should go g4 with some
decent winning chances after this white
had an interesting opportunity even
though you know both have one minute on
the clock it's not like if we analyze
this and and always just check the
engine and say a mistake mistake and
that sounds that they play terribly it's
just what you can do in one minute you
cannot play like the engine but we can
still look at the possible improvements
because it's sometimes they show
interesting ideas here g4 was a very
strong move that was missed by guey very
nice motif the idea is that after black
takes chances check check yeah see no
that's not possible let's idea clearance
also off their g3 square so take stakes
chattox and so check check and then back
here check and tier white will draw the
game probably and this is what he did
came to see 5g for King b6 app and now
after the following moves
check blackhat good winning shots yeah
however here age for it is a mistake he
should have played Knight c3 with still
good winning chances after that Giri
could have drawn the game but quite
surprisingly he didn't find that now
okay man here 20 seconds on the clock
here so we have to be a yeah realistic
him but rookie five no instead of
ninety-five would have drawn and once
you see the move it's not looking very
very difficult Black now has to take and
now we see that this this and this all
three black pieces yeah if you plead the
pawns everything went black has is a
check and wide would definitely now
managed to sacrifice the night on g4 and
take on c5 for a draw so that would have
been the final playoff spot for Geary
but he went 95 check and now he did not
go to h 7 which was still a fight and
probably a draw if he is precise he went
to age 8 after which mvl could take only
five for the night g6 fork and this was
game over Wow so get lost with white
here and they had to play an Armageddon
blitz game okay and that I'm again in
blitz game we will check now briefly we
have to be aware of the rules this was
six minutes for Geary but he had to win
with white and five minutes for mdl this
is not right 66 it's just that the ICC
cannot do a equal and I cannot do
unequal um Tom can see in their store
games mdl wasn't minute down five
minutes against six but give it to win
and note that mvl chose to play black so
he was basically claiming I don't think
that you can beat me it's not a not a
bad idea maybe give me is not yeah it's
not that great if he really has to push
hard for wind it's very safe
sound player anyway okay we had some
English opening here with III um that's
not such a bad choice if you need to win
a game just keep pieces on the board and
play try to get something complicated
yeah I don't want to analyze the Blitz
game in much detail there were what are
two interesting moments there especially
interesting was that Giri played the
opening phase here very quickly but
didn't have a particularly great
position after 9085 the following moves
are ya he went Queenie for now they are
all played really quickly but after
Bishop c8 I guess he noticed that it it
is troublesome now now what only has one
move to keep him get to keep keep him in
the game that is not be five it is to
play for counter check so something like
this this is the consequence however it
is a line that is immensely deep and
almost impossible to calculate for a
human player if you have no time the
first impression is that why does an
awful shape because of bad structure and
playing against the two bishops but this
is a tact and after a 596 bishop moves
94 we get this to a total draw it's a
crazy line it's like eight moves deep
it's a blitz game but just if you want
analysis this is what white had to do
it's not realistic that he finds this
but it's what he had to do he went
rookie one and now after Bishop f5 black
as a lot better rook fe8 also was strong
the mysterious moment of this game is
here where mdl did not take on d5 that's
kind of strange because loop takes d5
would have won the game pretty easily
and this also taking into account that
it is a blitz game I mean this is a
brilliant player
and it's kind of surprising to see that
you didn't didn't do that there's not
much to calculate white has taken out
check check King up and takes and wide
resigns hmm not quite sure not sure what
what you did not see they are on I know
it's just a complete win for Black Sun
rook takes d5 he played Bishop f5 though
pretty quickly and hereafter 93 blankets
of course okay but it's not the winner
when black had a very decent position
but it wasn't anything great note
however that giri has to win this game
and this is step difficult because if
anybody is better is black and in the in
the next couple of moves check Charlie
got here and this is kind of interesting
because wide now has nothing better then
check allow any repetition which
ultimately avoided because she has to
win the game they're white has to win
but the alternative was basically to get
here where you just lose yeah the night
is falling yeah that was a pretty
scrappy game in them in the Blitz there
but it is it is Blitzer and blitzes
always tricky business as we as we all
know okay so now for the for the final
so mdl against Carlton let's see what we
had what we had um Carlton had the first
game with white and they played into a
Sicilian hear that very classic aligned
with g6 check here 27 the whole game was
a fairly technical affair and I want to
go through it relatively quickly to just
focus on one or two moments in the end
game nothing much would happen in Carson
was taking a pawn here but after Queen
c5 we had some trades
and at the end a position where white
was a little bit more active them but it
wasn't anything special we got Jack at
the chance to a giant games I want to
talk about that end game a little bit
Carlton was avoiding the draw here first
and check and check the round chair we
always see that white has more activity
so its of course clear that if anybody
is better it's wild but it shouldn't be
anything special yeah here Carlton got
into that mentioned who can't game yeah
so how should black play this partial t
defend he has to defend because he has
to worry about the deep horn and whites
better King position it's not that black
is in any position to do or something
hereafter rookie three um he had a
couple of ways to play the move that he
played age form it's not bad in the
sense that it loses it still keeps a
draw in hand but it makes life a bit
more difficult than it then it needed to
be he could have played a rookie to for
example Jay and stayed on the D file
that would have been a pretty
straightforward way to draw for example
something like rook a three-year luckily
too um that's a check d 7 um okay to
check check can check check the King up
and now get to go for counter play and
this is a draw at the age pond will draw
against sarouk this is probably the
clean way to draw it or something like
that it's not a totally first thing he
went age four and after g4 it got a
little bit tricky so the next couple of
moves are all I think rather rather
logical but we come to this critical
position now King here and here and this
is the critical position now
interestingly enough
um there is some only one totally clear
way to draw and this is now yeah it's
missed by mdl he goes rook f1 and after
that he loses he absolutely loses the
game what he had to do was aged to
rookie to and now go to a won't be one
or c1 to switch back to a frontal
defense so something like this and here
and now black can check from the front
and draw the game like that if why does
try to set up a barrier black and I will
check and the pawn is far back enough so
that black has enough space for the rope
to check that was the draw yeah but he
didn't he didn't find that he had time
on the clock he went here and this is
now losing interestingly enough because
black is not getting with his King in
front of the porn anymore check check
check yeah and here he resigned so just
a blackout in a way it's for the player
of that level it's I mean if you are
looking at this with a clear head not
after who tournament and blitz and
everything yeah he sees that of course
but it's a bit of a bit of a shame or
what happened there 44 m VL yeah this is
a lost lost position why because black
is not getting in front of the Jeep on
anymore with the King and at the end
wide will win possibly with the lucena
maneuver the bridge building it's
something that you can look at look up
in one of my videos i made a video once
on basic routine games so this was the
wind for kazem and we had one more game
of course and mdl still could have
equalized with with white with a wide
win but that was kind of a I'm not going
to make anything up yet was quite
unspectacular he tried this opening
which can be interesting if black no
place a six or something like that
but Carson just played fire fear just a
complete block in the center and this
game never got started ready it's just
completely it's it's closed end it
nothing much happens and it's the kind
of position where you sometimes can get
something in the long run there but
nothing much happened in this game it
was just completely a complete shuffle
yeah in fact what God is rook trapped
and try to make make something out of
that with an exchange down so Carlton
was just better here but he needed a
draw to to win the whole thing and this
is what ultimately happened at some
point here I think just offered to drive
i'm not mistaken or they made a
repetition here yeah so this was kind of
an anti climatic finish with this
somewhat boring game you buy MBL so the
overall winner of the London event and
the grand chest tourism George champion
magnus carlsen quite surprised after the
um yeah somewhat meager start of six
drawers but then he won a great game
against nakamura and also one that
decisive game against Greece shook in
the final round with luck with luck
definitely he didn't really was on at
his best but at the end he won the
overall event so good nurse in the final
with that with that rook endgame again
he's really an endgame specialist I hope
you enjoyed the coverage of that event
it was a little bit late the final
rounds but I was glad to have gotten it
in in the first place thanks a lot for
watching